what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with invincible yes we are uh
we are covering well really the first
part of the last war this is the second
to last story arc right the end of all
things part one after this it's the end
of all things part two and invincible's
over so uh yeah it'll it will be crazy
but uh nonetheless right in the last
video we talked about how oliver had
basically been killed by freddie mercury
right freddie mercury killed him and
that oliver had actually been a spy for
freddie mercury but when his loyalty was
tested and he had to make the choice
between letting freddie mercury kill
mark or stepping in he chose to step in
and so what we actually end up getting
here is basically the funeral for for uh
oliver here and again one of the things
you guys probably know over the course
of your lives if you've attended
funerals or anything along those lines
is that behind all the tears there's
usually anger right there's usually a
lot of anger and a lot of pain right and
if that's not dealt with it can wreak
havoc on a person's life and the result
of this is that where alan the alien
tells mark you know i'm i'm so very
sorry mark freaks now one thing to
understand is that there is motivation
behind this mark does have a reason for
being angry at allen alien but the
reality is that with all that pain we as
people we usually need someone to look
to as the reason for why that exists
right if we are in a an emotionally
unhealthy place we need an enemy right
there has to be a person who's the bad
guy right often times we have a very
difficult time accepting the fact that
sometimes bad things just happen that
sometimes it's not necessarily because
any one particular person did anything
that oftentimes is because of our own
personal choices and so it's one of
those things where in turn a fight kind
of breaks out between the two but it's
not really a fight per se i mean alan
the alien is kind of fighting back to a
degree he's not letting mark just beat
him up right take all his anger out on
him but he's not trying to assault mark
right he's not trying to like beat mark
to make him stop instead he's playing
more defensive than anything else but
what he tries to tell mark is that the
reality here is that oliver was a double
agent right that oliver was basically
working for alan alien pretending to
work for freddie mercury that oliver had
basically volunteered for this that it
was the only way to get the advantage
over freddie mercury the that freddie
mercury had to believe there was someone
on the inside but there was someone
there who had allied himself with him
that could feed him information for the
coalition of planets and that the reason
why allen agreed to do this was really
just desperation that it didn't really
seem like there was a possible way for
them to win now we'll also find out
there's more going on here than
initially meets the eye but one of the
things that happens is that where mark's
dad wants to step in and like where
mark's mom wants to step in different
people want to step in the reality here
is that they're all basically told by
adam eve no right like i will be the one
to step in and i will be the one to say
something none of you do anything here
right if anything all you're going to do
is make it worse
nolan you're a cool guy man but every
time you get involved things get worse
right
stay away and so ultimately adam eve
shows up now let me tell you guys
something any of you guys ever been in a
long-term meaningful relationship you
guys know sometimes dealing with like an
enemy is better than dealing with a
pissed off girl just saying
right hell half no fury like a woman
scorned i'm just saying right like
that's that's sometimes you're just kind
of better off in that situation and so
eve shows up here but instead of like
simply stopping the fight she makes a
great point here she turns on mark and
she was like look i know you're mad and
i know you're really irritated but
here's the thing right when mark says
you know i'm sorry i just lost control
she's like yeah and you decided to do
something stupid mark you always do that
you always rush in and you never stop
and you never think and you never ask
the question what am i actually doing
here right why am i actually doing this
right you always rush in headlong you
never focus and what this does and this
is a really interesting thing what this
does is all this anger and all this pain
that adam eve has built up over all this
time she uses on mark like she literally
lashes out at mark and just goes goes
nuts on him because it's just nothing
but pain and sadness that she felt for
the last five years because she knew
that mark would have been there had mark
not rushed into that situation rushed
into that conflict had he not so quickly
volunteered to go with oliver to that
planet where thrag was supposedly at and
try to find him and try to defeat him
because thrag may have been weak right i
mean it was one of those things where
like mark never seems to put her first
right in those situations mark never
chooses her and sometimes that's just
what the girl wants right sometimes
that's what a woman wants that in a
situation where you could choose
something else she wants you to choose
her and that's ultimately the mistake
that mark made that there were plenty of
times when he could have said look i
would love to but my girl's more
important than that and so adam eve is
of course able to sort of calm things
down to a degree but then she starts to
grieve herself and says it hurts so bad
because she loved oliver too and that's
one of the things that really kind of
hits home is because when you look at
mark's reaction mark was angry at alan
the alien but at no point did marx stop
and ask adam eve you know like why are
you doing this it's one of those
interesting situations because you
basically have this scenario where adam
eve says look like once they calm down
she's like look i totally get this war
that we're about to get into it could
cost us our lives we could die here
we're not going to take our daughter
with us she can't be with us because
she's not powerful enough she'd never
survive but we could very well die and
if that's going to happen mark then
we're going to do something we're going
to do the thing that i've wanted to do
for the last five years and when mark
says what's that they get married mark
and adam eve finally get married and you
guys know it was a long time coming you
guys know it was a long time coming and
it's so cool to see right it's so so
cool to see these two finally end up
getting married right they finally end
up tying the nut and then ultimately
once the marriage is done right once the
ceremony is done and the happiness is
over and they were presumably you know
doing the damn thing you know uh then
it's one of those things worse is kind
of like okay now it's time to go to war
the the dark side of this and what you
end up doing is switching over to allen
the alien and this is the crazy thing is
because what happens here is that he has
this kind of confession that he makes to
his wife right now notice this right
when she comes out she says alan what
are you doing out here by yourself and
alan says it's all in motion now mark
and eve will want to kill freddie
mercury for what he did they're involved
they'll give me the help that i need i
can rally my forces around them mark
will be able to pull in nolan and the
other viltromites something oliver could
never do and when she says i know you
lost a friend but isn't all this good
news and he says yes it's good news
that's exactly what it is and he says
the attack on my life there was so much
pressure i didn't have a choice please
tell ya i need you to believe i never
thought it would get this out of hand
and then ultimately that's when it
starts to dawn on her what was going on
and allen says i knew pressing oliver to
meet with with freddie mercury would
cause freddie mercury to test oliver i
made sure that freddie mercury knew
where mark and adam eve were i knew
freddy would use them as a test i knew
all of this i was desperate i saw no
other way and now my friend is dead that
in essence allen betrayed them alan knew
for a fact that with oliver working for
freddie mercury that when all when he
when when when the location was leaked
to where it was that uh that adam eve
and mark were that freddie would respond
and he knew that oliver would be tested
but he never expected that oliver would
die right he basically gambled and he
lost he lost big but the other thing
that comes out of this is it was a risk
he was willing to take because now what
he's done is he's given mark and he's
given adam eve motivation this is game
theory what decision do you make when
the success of your decisions depends on
the decisions of others right the
prisoner's dilemma if you want to call
it that that's exactly what this is
right nash equilibrium the death of
oliver will now lead to mark basically
being like fighting alongside them which
is something that he had previously told
alan alien he wouldn't do that he and
adam eve would not fight alongside him
in his war at least the final war
against freddie mercury but with oliver
being dead now mark and adam eve are
going to fight more so than that the
hope of alan is that now mark can
basically galvanize nolan and all the
other vulture mites on earth right it's
kind of nuts and so following that you
kind of pick up with this moment with
freddie mercury and his daughter where
his daughter is basically grieving the
loss of their brother remember he was
killed like he was he was killed by mark
and it's one of those things where when
his daughter shows a moment of sentiment
it angers freddie mercury it makes him
so mad but he pretends to be okay with
it and he pretends to tell her you know
i'm so sorry about what happened because
he needs her but it's one of those crazy
things where if for no other reason than
to assuage his own guilty conscience
alan comes clean to mark and to adam eve
now the truth about this is that it's a
smart thing to do it's better to it's
better that alan be the one to tell them
what he did as opposed to somebody else
telling them because what it will mean
is that alan hid that from them it'll
it'll not simply be just one betrayal
but two right sometimes it's just better
to bite the bullet and when he tells
mark i mean mark just gets angrier and
angrier right adam eve gets more and
more pissed off and finally adam eve
lashes out on on allen and then actually
starts to kill him right like the nature
of her powers is such that alan can't
overcome it now allen's wife tries to
tell you know them going on like hey
look he made a mistake right i mean have
you never made a mistake right he was
desperate you know he felt like there
was nothing else he could do and
ultimately mark carl calls it off and
then mark mark says no we i made you a
promise i will fight alongside you i
will honor that and then i will try to
galvanize my father and i will try to
see if we can't find a way for nolan and
the rest of the villager might to get
involved here the immediate response of
nolan is no that's not going to happen
and again it makes sense because he says
there's so few of us as velcromites left
when i become a king my loyalty is to
the people and that's true nolan is now
the ruler he's the emperor of the
vilture might race he can't be reckless
he can't be one of these guys where he's
just like sure well put my entire race
at risk and it's entirely it's entirely
possible that all of us could be
destroyed and my entire race could be
eradicated like sure that's exactly
something that i could do ah but i'm not
going to right because as a king his
duty is to his people his duty is not to
himself it's not to his motivations he
believes they should get involved he
thinks it's the right thing to do to get
involved but the needs of his people
outweigh what he wants right it's simple
utilitarianism the needs of the many
outweigh the needs of the few and so
ultimately mark calls him out and says
no like your son died like your son died
as a result of freddie mercury do you
have no desire for revenge do you have
no desire to see this guy come to an end
and lest we forget nolan you're the one
who let freddie mercury go free anyway
so if anything it's your fault that our
son is dead and that's the thing while
it pisses off nolan to no end ultimately
he's right right mark is right and so no
one says okay fine you know i will not
command my people to fight alongside you
in your war right to fight alongside me
in this war because obviously he's going
to join mark but i will give them the
opportunity i will give them the option
i will let them decide what it is that
they want to do do they want to fight
alongside or do they want to simply just
walk away and so the result of this is
that you end up switching over to
basically mark and adam eve donning
their costumes right their daughter
thinks it's absolutely hilarious because
she thinks they look goofy you know when
she's like this cape i mean the cape
looks you know it's like i mean the
whole outfit like really this is what
you guys wear she's like so people on
earth wear tights and go around and and
fight like what kind of sense does that
make which is kind of a funny critique
on the superhero landscape right i mean
what kind of sense does it make right
like why can't spider-man just fight
people in jeans right you know when when
she explains how it is that the whole
thing works right maneuverability all
that kind of stuff her daughter's like
so i mean does the cape make you move
faster and adam he's like no girl the
cape just looks cute you know and her
daughter's like yeah the cape plays and
that'll be like yeah the cape plays it
it works you know and so her daughter's
like i want a cape and it's like yeah of
course you do capes are amazing right
like capes are awesome
[Laughter]
and so what they end up doing is
basically spending this last day with
their daughter right spending time with
them hanging out having all the fun in
the world because the truth is they may
never see her again right this may be
the very last time that they ever see
her and so of course once battle
formations are prepared once it's time
to leave they end up leaving tara with
with debbie right with mark's mom and
the two of them basically head forward
with the intention of galvanizing their
forces and going from there now alan the
alien does have a plan right he does
have a plan on how it is that he thinks
they can win but the response of mark is
no i think we have a better idea here
and so over the course of this war
really we don't necessarily get like all
the finer points instead what freddie
mercury's been doing is traveling from
world to world and then conquering it
and then basically conscripting people
or forcing people to fight in this army
in reality it's an old roman empire
tactic that's what made the roman empire
so powerful for like 800 years is when
the roman empire rolled into a territory
and conquered it ah there were a few
things that happened one when you were
conquered by the romans you became a
roman and that's just how it was right
like you became a roman you worshiped in
the roman belief system and if you were
an able-bodied man you likely fought in
the roman army there was no arguing that
point now you do end up having mark and
his guys who show up on the scene start
taking pot shots and are able to sort of
liberate one of these planets or some of
these territories from the the forces of
uh of freddie mercury which limits his
ability to allow people to fight on his
behalf but they are able to save some of
these worlds now one of the other things
that happens is that one of the members
of his army is actually allowed to leave
because what this does is it allows
space racer to follow this guy and find
out where the forces of a freddie
mercury are operating out of one of the
other things that happens here is
freddie mercury actually shows up to the
home world of battle beast and having
defeated battle beast basically the
emperor just bends the knee and while
his uh his ambassador is just kind of
like no like why would you do this like
all he's going to do is enslave us the
response of of the emperor is kill that
man right they kill that guy right on
the spot and the entirety of battle
beast's race ends up bending the knee to
freddie mercury so now he's got them on
his side and that's just kind of how
this continues over and over and over
again more so than that and this is a
particularly important thing one of the
things that uh that freddie mercury's
daughter begins to realize is that he
doesn't really care about them when one
of his sons when when freddie mercury
comes back and one of his sons says you
know in honor of your recent victory i
present you with this gift his son just
gets smacked to the side so there's no
real concern or no real love for the the
members of like for his own children and
this doesn't go unnoticed by his
daughter you know and it's one of those
things where he's kind of where she's
kind of like okay so like it doesn't
really seem like our father cares about
us all that much but because of the fact
that the home base of freddie mercury
has been discovered this leads to the
forces of the coalition of worlds
launching their strike on freddie
mercury's home world there's a few
things that go on right this is one of
those things that's really really
interesting when this happens freddie
mercury says okay fine battle formations
right everybody's strike and that's also
because he expected this right one of
the things to remember is that freddie
mercury has been alive for thousands of
years he was the grand region for the
vulture might race for thousands of
years so he has so much battle
experience he knows how to plan battle
strategy in one of the most effective
ways but this is all part of mark's plan
the one thing they didn't expect is how
many offspring freddie mercury had right
remember with the race that he was
procreating with their children grow at
an accelerated rate so while it's only
been five years since freddie mercury
basically started procreating with that
alien race the same race that oliver was
born from uh in reality all these guys
have aged 20 years or so right so
they're all probably between the ages of
like 20 and 30 right maybe some of them
are closer to like 35 possibly 40 but
like they've all they're all basically
older teenagers and adults is really
what this is more so than that these
guys are in a lot of way cannon fodder
because they're just flinging themselves
freddie mercury is approaching this from
the perspective of a war of attrition
just throw overwhelming numbers at them
and then try to win right and that's
because there's probably hundreds of
thousands of these kids right just so
many of them just launching themselves
the other part of this though is that
for somebody like mark or somebody like
nolan they're much stronger than these
kids are because these kids powers
haven't developed in the same way and
that's one of the things that freddie
mercury realized none of these kids are
seemingly on the same level as mark his
daughter and his son were but like
that's basically it and he's lost one of
them so now his daughter is the only one
that's seemingly on the same level as
mark and the response or at least the
result of this is that when these kids
throw themselves their physical bodies
are destroyed adam eve is able to hold
them off as best she can right just kind
of forcing these guys or or like cutting
them to pieces and so on and so forth
she's able to operate pretty effectively
but then the daughter of freddie mercury
appears to him and it's like they're all
breaking rank right like we've got them
on the run this battle is basically won
but like what's the cost of this victory
right like the forces of the coalition
they can't defeat us here right that's
why they're breaking rig oh at what cost
has this battle been won and when
ferdinand mercury is like what are you
talking about she says like my brothers
and sisters are dying right they're
throwing themselves at the enemy and
it's killing them do you not see the
body count here and the response of
freddie mercury is i don't care the
fallen were weak and it is our way to
cast them off our empire will be built
with the strong we will be stronger from
this battle it has tempered us it is not
your place to question my will or my
motives if you feel such pity for the
weak let me know and you can join them
right like i will kill you right here
and right now it's this just this
extremely hardcore philosophy of freddie
mercury but here is the important thing
that does not go unnoticed right do not
let his daughter daughter's pacifism
trick you into believing that she's okay
with this but he ends up saying like
when the forces of the coalition take
off and mark says no no no everything's
cool guys it's all going to plan the
response of freddie mercury is like they
think they can escape no that's not
going to happen i will not allow them to
lick their wounds and attack us again we
finish this now right launch the fleet
and then in turn they follow the
coalition of worlds they follow them
directly back because then the question
becomes because alan's not fully fully
made aware of this plan the question
becomes okay mark what's the next thing
that we do and the response of mark is
we're leading them to earth we're
leading them directly back to our world
and so what you end up getting is
basically nolan you know addressing the
entirety of the vulture might race on
earth and basically saying freddie
mercury is coming right and he's
bringing his entire vilture mind army
they outnumber us probably a thousand to
one but they are not strong as us yet
they're basically newborns right they're
they're the equivalent of human newborns
they could not pose a threat to like a
regular adult unless they want to give
you a cold then they'll certainly pose a
threat in that capacity you know but
nonetheless you know it's just one of
those things you know where it's like
like we can overcome them quite readily
but here's the thing i recognize many of
you have started families here many of
you have husbands or wives and you have
children you've made earth your home and
i understand you may very well die in
this conflict so i am not directing you
i am not ordering you or ordering you to
assist us i am simply asking that you
consider it right if you want to fight
come and fight if you don't stay home
and there will be no shame on those who
choose to stay home i was one of you i
understand the response here almost
unanimously is no we will fight right
like earth is our home and if he is
coming here then we will protect our
home we will just like we'll face off
against the forces of freddie mercury
and if that means we die then that means
we die now one of the other things that
i want to address here and this is kind
of a lingering plot that i'm sure some
of you guys would ask about if we
skipped over it is mark's conversation
with nolan about the fact that anissa
had forced herself on him now one of the
things to understand is that nolan is
actually the one who figures it out
nolan's like she forced herself on you
didn't she and the response of mark well
lee smart doesn't necessarily answer but
he might as well have said yes right he
just he didn't say no and then
ultimately mark says like i didn't tell
you because i didn't want you to kill
her right i know we need every vulture
might that we had and ultimately nolan's
response is like i'm angry right anissa
hurt you but it's difficult for me to
process mark he says our vulture might
strong choose their mate as their as
their right right they just that's just
how it was we routinely killed each
other right we call the weak and so
according to traditional viltrumite
philosophies that's just what you do
right anissa found mark as somebody
attractive anissa's stronger than mark
and anisa says that's my mate and forced
herself on him right for her she wasn't
doing anything wrong for mark it was
i've just been i'm a victim of sexual
assault and so nolan ultimately says you
know the the anissa who did that to you
i promise you she's not here anymore but
what nolan does not do for mark is say
she will be reprimanded for what she did
instead nolan's response is i know it's
hard to accept mark but she didn't
believe she was doing anything wrong
according to viltromites that's just our
way and that's one of the things that's
kind of crazy is because he doesn't
necessarily side with his son or he
doesn't necessarily say like yes she was
wrong mark he's just he tries to help
mark understand why she did what she did
now the other thing that goes on here is
you have the daughter of freddie mercury
of course visiting some of the children
who were injured and what's so crazy
about this is is ultimately like they
you know they apologize for not dying
and when she's like why are you
apologizing for not dying their response
is well because if i did uh if i died in
his honor then he would learn my name
right like he would care about me you
know and that's when she starts to
realize how twisted and screwed up their
perspectives are that they're willing to
die for freddie mercury not because they
believe in the cause but because they
just want him to love them which is so
twisted and so screwed up when you think
about it but what ends up happening here
of course is that adam eve is basically
made to stay behind while they while
they make their way to earth because she
can't breathe in space right she doesn't
have that capacity and mark even says
like if you were to be injured or
knocked unconscious you would die
immediately and with everything that's
going on and the sheer numbers i'm
afraid i wouldn't be able to get to you
in time or i wouldn't even be aware of
the fact that it had happened you would
just be dead out there in the
battlefield and i wouldn't know until
the dust settled so he's like i want you
to stay here and i want you to be safe i
know you want to fight but this is not a
battle you can fight in and so as the
forces begin to catch up uh mark asked
the question so like i'm just kind of
curious though like is there a reason
that we're flying so close to the sun
and the response of alan is we're flying
that close because the forces of the
viltromites are on the other side of
that sun right they're heading this way
and basically they're going to surprise
the forces of freddie mercury when they
arrive here now the funny thing about
this is that when freddie mercury gets
here he counted on this like he never
forgot that the vulture might race lives
on earth and he expected the viltrumites
on earth to be here and as a result of
that he brought those beasts that are
one of the only things in the universe
capable of killing the viltrumites right
of like killing vulture mites themselves
because he knows his children aren't
capable of defeating those vulture mites
they'll rip right through them right
they would tear right through them in in
the blink of an eye and so even the
viltrumites themselves are you know
didn't really expect this they didn't
really see it coming and they face off
as best they can but freddie mercury's
battle preparations seem to be more than
they were initially ready for and so in
the midst of this great big huge
conflict finally it comes to a head you
basically get the rematch between nolan
and freddie mercury and this battle is
intense this battle between the two is
extreme i mean it's a no holds barred
knock down drag out fight right it is
it's bloody and in every conceivable way
mark's facing off against seemingly all
the children taking pot shots and all
that kind of stuff but uh but the fight
between the two is brutal and in fact
there's one point when freddie mercury
tells nolan like you should have killed
me when you had the chance and it's one
of those things because where the fight
between nolan and freddie mercury seemed
relatively even the first time they
fought freddie mercury reveals i was
just leading you on i was baiting you
and this comes to a head when nolan goes
to punch freddie mercury in the head and
nothing like freddie mercury is
completely uninjured and that ultimately
it just ends up smashing the hand of
nolan in the process i mean that was
assuming nolan ever even had a chance in
the first place mark steps in and tries
to help nolan where he can but the
response of freddie mercury is no you'll
have your turn just be patient and he
literally throws mark into his children
and the children just start throwing
themselves against mark at that point
freddie mercury just starts overpowering
nolan and this guy never had a chance i
mean literally it's a headbutt it's a
punch right like like nolan does what he
can but the response of freddie mercury
is like well done right in my absence
you were the most qualified to lead the
problem is i have no further is planned
and in doing so punches a hole through
nolan now of course nolan moved out of
the way an instant to make sure that his
heart was not injured and that that you
know of course the response of freddie
is like impressive you know move to the
last minute protecting your heart a
lesson you should have taught your son
you know and when nolan's like it's
going to take more than that for you to
defeat me ultimately freddie mercury
rips him in half like he literally tears
nolan's body apart and kills nolan on
the spot with that being said guys we're
going to bring this video to an end yes
like i told you guys velcro my war or
the the last war man i told you guys
when we first started covering this
right like the ending of invincible is
absolutely crazy because this is just
the beginning with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this to an end thank
you all for watching and i will catch
you all later peace